à se connecter sur mon profil voilà
j'arrive ce matin coucou les
célibataires oui j'ai pas de copain quoi
j'ai pas de copains montre moi une photo
de toi là où tu préfères ça donne c'est
dégueu pourquoi tu fais ça j'ai 12 ans
voici les propos donnent adultes %
interagir avec une fillette de 12 ans
sur facebook pour aller faire un petit
tour rapidement
oui je t'enverrai bien des photos d'elle
toute nue mais sur facebook on ne peut
pas à ok ou secteur n'atteint aube stars
dont je ne devrais pas dire ça tu veux
voir
ah oui j'en ai plein d'autres le profil
de l'enfant est un faux il a été créé
par maria une mère de famille française
appartenant à un collectif citoyen la
team moore s'est donné pour mission de
protéger des enfants des prédateurs
sexuels dès sa création ou profitent de
cette fausse petite fille un profil
comme celui ci a attiré des centaines
d'hommes des internautes de tous âges
qui montrent leurs parties génitales se
masturbe devant l'écran on voit même des
images pédopornographiques à leur petit
interlocutrice menaces propos obscènes
manipulation proposition de rendez vous
une plongée dans l'horreur un enfant
qu'il a parlé comme ça certains
individus la titiller elle va avoir peur
elle va envoyer elle va cacher elle pas
avoir de mauvaises notes à l'école elle
va se cacher elle a pu manger elle elle
va être malade détruite à rien monte
ensuite un dossier avec des éléments de
preuve qui sera envoyée aux maires aux
forces de gendarmerie et de police et au
procureur
la team moore qui a formé 1600 personnes
suit un protocole pour rester dans la
légalité
mon faux profils sont réalisés avec des
photos personnelles il s'appuie sur
l'article 227 21 ans qui établit que les
propositions sexuelles un mineur une
personne se disant mineure est passible
de deux ans d'emprisonnement
steven humour un père de famille
réunionnais à qui l'on doit ces
initiatives en france s'en explique nous
respectons scrupuleusement la loi
nous ne faisons en aucun cas
d'incitation ou de harponnage donc nous
ne provoquons pas le pays et pour
terminer nous ne diffusons pas ces
échanges ou l'identité des présumé
prédateur sexuel
on ne pas enfreindre l'atteinte à la vie
privée
un enfant sur cinq serait victime
d'agression sexuelle en france cela
laisse imaginer l'ampleur du drame de la
pédophilie dans l'hexagone malgré cela
le discours officiel de certains
responsables de la police et d'appeler à
l'arrêt de telles activités pourtant les
initiatives de la digue nous ont déjà
permis 50 interpellations 28
arrestations
avec treize condamnations à la clé
véronique b chef de la dcpj groupe
central de m'énerver
décliner notre interview 11 septembre
elle ne disposait que de 14
cyberpatrouilleurs qui effectué 250
saisine environ par an une goutte d'eau
dans un océan de requins dans la presse
elle fustige les activités de la team
moore estimant qu'ils sont hors la loi
alors qu'on se montre toujours très
scrupuleux et que police et justice
collaborent souvent avec eux en sous
main mais voilà ce qu'elle déclare à
mediapart
il faudrait que nous soyons dix fois
plus pourquoi nous dérangeons les
autorités elles le disent régulièrement
un kiss régulièrement que nous
inquiétons à aucun moment
jamais on dit que les gens que nous
remettrons à la justice les inquiéter
faut savoir que nous avons mis des
membres de réseaux pédophiles des des
multirécidivistes des kidnappeurs
d'enfants aux autorités françaises que
belges ou canadiennes
cette situation révolte comme ailleurs à
celje présidente de l'association
innocence en danger
il ya un problème dans un pays comme la
france qui n'est pas prêt pour cette
traque qui n'a ni les outils ni
suffisamment de deux personnes formées
pour mener ce type de travecy il faut
trouver un cadre pour cette
collaboration parce que pour moi ça doit
être une collaboration si il faut
trouver un cadre juridique mais trouvons
le cette responsabilité incombe au
gouvernement
la team moore s'entretiendra
prochainement avec une députée pour
tenter de faire avancer la lutte contre
la pédophilie en france un combat auquel
le gouvernement a jusqu'ici donné si peu
d'armes et de combattants